like the point of business and money is
like to live a really long and good life
and the really the best way to do that
money is maybe number two number one is
just like being fit and I wanted to
spend 10 minutes talking about my
personal well I was like what do
engineers say they say like Tech stack
marketing stack let's talk about our
body stack
[Music]
all right it's Friday and uh we're gonna
do something a little different so you
know people know us than it was for our
brains
they know us for our money
but they also know us for our body
me and Sam were doing an episode and for
some reason we got on a 30-minute
tangent about
Fitness as an entrepreneur Fitness as a
uh as a business person what we do uh
more specifically like what's the
routines what are the uh what are the
things that are working for us what are
the tactics what are the goals we have
things like that uh so we decided to
make it a separate episode so this is uh
this is the body episode of my
personality let us know if you like it
Sam what did uh what are they gonna get
by listening to this I name drop lots of
products that I pay for none of these
people have paid me I'm more than happy
to accept payment from them so if you're
yeah you know my fitness pal yeah if I
use MyFitnessPal I love it so if you
guys want to give me some money just put
it out there if you are one of these
companies or a competitor to one of
these companies pay us yeah willing to
be bought uh so anyway it's a 30 minute
episode on or is it 30 maybe 20 on uh
different Fitness stuff and the things
that we spend our money on to be fit
which basically is kind of more
important than the whole making money
thing because if you're not fit and
you're not healthy you can't really do
that thing so we talked about one of our
friends as one of our friends who's uh
you know super successful they've been a
guest on the podcast before worth
hundreds of millions of dollars they
said this once and I can't use their
name because it's a little not
politically correct but they said this
if you're rich there's no excuse to be
fat
and
they said that because I was like man
you spend a lot of time like working out
like what are you trying to do here and
they just said like look the point of
having Financial Freedom is to be able
to spend it on spend your time doing
things that are like you know luxuries
things that like make your life better
and one of the things that makes your
life way better is having a good like
kind of Fitness routine and being a you
know a healthy fit person and so that's
kind of the idea Sam is extremely fit
Samuel like in the
top point one percent probably of like
Founders who are fit well yeah I mean
that's I I added the founder Venn
diagram yeah give me that founder thing
and yeah we'll definitely call it point
one percent but you know that's like
that's an easy that's an easy game to
win maybe and I've been going from
pretty unfit to now like you know as we
say I was the before before photo
and I'm getting to the after and so you
get both perspectives you get the
perspective of somebody who's like all
about that life and somebody who is like
you know doesn't come easy to them but
they're they're making it happen so so
yeah enjoy the episode
all right we live what's going on
how are you I'm sore
from what
so I went I went on Craigslist because I
had I wanted something I think
Craigslist is massively underrated
Craigslist is so good there is if you
want a job Craigslist if you're on a
couch Craigslist if you want to learn
something Craigslist if you want to hook
up Craigslist whatever you want
Craigslist has got the thing for you and
it has the most liquidity so you go in
there and I I was looking for a um
a new uh new chef and so I went on there
and I was like you Chef immediately
started getting hit with things and I
was like why don't I use Craigslist more
look at these responses this is amazing
so I was like what else do I want right
Craigslist is my like magic lamp this
the genie and I need to go and I need to
make another wish and so I go
oh yeah remember that video of Mark
Zuckerberg and so this is the part I
learned from you which is describe it
like a kid with no filter so I literally
just put up a video I I put up the post
I go
uh Hey I was watching I was on Tick Tock
and I saw this video it looked awesome I
want to do that
so I was like I want to do that that
looks fun and I was like will you come I
was like will somebody come to my house
to just like train me kind of like that
yeah I don't I'm not I'm a beginner and
I don't even really want to ever fight I
just think that looks like a really fun
workout so I want to do that
um I don't know who I need you don't
have to be an expert just like somebody
who could just watch that video and if
you think you could do that for me then
uh just call me or maybe text me
whatever
so I posted that and immediately guy I
got a hit from some guy who's like hey
uh I did anime for 10 years I could
totally trade you he's like I trained
with the Diaz brothers in in Stockton
and you know I'm a Caesar Gracie purple
belt I'm a striker but I was like whoa
okay great he's like
he's like um and so he calls me
and I'm like all right yeah um do I need
like equipment or like how do I do this
and he was just like no you he's like
you don't need anything I was like what
do you do during the day he's like I'm a
handyman
and I was like he's like oh this is cool
because I'll get back into shape too and
I was like all right sounds fun and he's
like uh did he like fix a bunch of stuff
afterwards at your house no but in my
mind I was like dude I've been looking
for a handyman too my wife's always on
me about building and assembling things
and hanging things I was like this is a
two-for-one baby and so which basically
means this guy is like a professor like
his he's the reason he was on Craigslist
he was probably looking for handyman
gigs yeah exactly he just happened to
see this was like oh I used to whoop ass
and so he goes um
I knew he would be good he goes what are
you doing today
and I was like uh uh uh I was like
mentally not prepared to like
immediately get in a fight today so I
was like no but how about tomorrow he's
like all right I'll be there what time I
was like I don't know uh let's do the
morning he goes great I'll be there at 8
A.M okay and so he came over we trained
and he came over by the way looking like
a handyman he comes over in his like
handyman boots his like you know like
those jeans that are like covered in
paint and he's like rolls up he's got
like a pair he's got a set of keys that
has like 1400 keys on it I was like bro
do you have the keys to my house what's
going on here and so he just got all
these Keys oh he brings his boots and
he's just like so he's one of these guys
that works out in his jeans or what yeah
so he basically did the whole workout in
his jeans which was crazy to me he's
like throwing kicks in his combat boots
and I was like what the hell is going on
uh but he knew what he was talking about
and so he trained me and I'm still super
sore it was incredible my hand I had to
ice my Knuckles my hand was in so much
pain last night it was great I don't
know if this is legit
did he did some did he do a little
reference checking like I don't know if
that's how it works no no I don't do
reference checks that's all right did
you guys like Risk at all times did you
like wrestle or do Jiu Jitsu like did
you roll what did you do
yeah well he's like all right we're
gonna start with the basics he's like
here's how you move your feet he's like
here you say you throw a jab he said
throw you across and it's like and you
know you know these things but he's like
you know clean it up right like let's do
these right
um and then but I told him I was like
dude I don't want to just learn tactics
like I'm not here to learn technique
I'll learn just enough technique to make
the session worth it I was like I was
like you know that video I was like the
I want the sweat that they were breaking
I want the way that they were breaking
that sweat a competitive sweat is what
I'm looking for and then he he hits me
with this he goes yeah I didn't watch
the video but I I got an idea what you
want I was like bro there's only one
thing in that it was one video you don't
even watch the video he's like no and uh
but at the end we basically like sparred
and so for 10 minutes we just like
fought and it was amazing my
brother-in-law came so uh long time this
is the Pod no brother Aaron he he was
there Aaron he kind of like vouched or
not vouch but he kind of checked the guy
out
uh no not that he checked the guy out he
was just like my sparring partner to do
the thing dude I'm reading this is so
funny you're bringing this up this
morning you know I listened to like
three audio books a week this because I
go I like walking why why you know I
like walking and uh the book that I'm
listening to now is called when violence
is the answer and far
[Laughter]
and the premises is that basically like
violence is rarely the answer but when
it is it's the only answer and when it
is the only answer you want to act fast
and as violently as possible
and uh it just tells like stories and
like he's like I'm not teaching you
tactics well we're gonna talk principles
and that the whole book is basically
like
when you have to be violent you want to
annihilate them as fast as possible and
take their mind completely out of the
equation because like it's like if you
ever given like punched in the balls
you're like oh I can't fight like
there's nothing I can think about right
right or imagine like being in a fight
and like just having your elbow broken
you know what I mean you're like I can't
do anything right now like I don't even
want to think about this versus like
punch in the face sometimes you could
still like anyway
it's so funny you're doing this now
because I'll have to give you the cliff
notes of when violence is the answer as
soon as I dig deeper into it
anyways it was an amazing workout and I
think my takeaway is uh Zuck and his
inner so Zuck went on Joe Rogan he was
talking about it and Joe's like you're
doing MMA now and he's like yeah you
know uh I just whatever he gives some
reason for starting he goes
he goes it's not like why are you doing
MMA it's more he's like now that I'm
doing it I'm like why have I not been
doing this my whole life because this is
it's clearly the best and he says it
like it's such a you know computer nerd
sort of way where it's like I've found
the best workout right like it's like in
the office what is the best bear
there is a best bear so that's how he
was saying it and I was like
um yeah exactly false Eminem is the best
bear and so that's how I that's not when
he said that I was like that's probably
right and uh I like the idea of getting
competitive sweat in the morning and I
told the guy I go look I'm gonna sit at
my keyboard all day after this but like
if I could start the day with kind of
like a this like very intense can't
think about anything else type of
workout right like extreme focus is
required my mind is not going to be
drifting around thinking about the to-do
list and about this and about that my
email no I'm gonna be locked into this
it's a very primal thing I'm gonna break
it huge sweat and then I can go on with
my day and everything else in my day I
will have uh it'll be much easier I know
I'm preaching the choir with you but I I
feel like that's been my uh my
realization with it so I wanna and I
actually I wanted to spend 10 minutes
and bring this topic up because you sent
me this gym picture and your gym looked
sick and I and like two years ago or a
year and a half ago you saw mine and
you're like I'm gonna get one and you
got one and it looks awesome and then
like four years ago maybe you weren't in
the best of shape and you've made a big
difference and so have I in terms of
fitness and I was thinking I saw this
guy he's a picture of a 71 year old his
name's Mark he started Primal or uh
Primal kitchen I think it's called and
it's like a sauce business that I love
but he's 71 years old and he shared this
picture of him and he just looks great
he's not like huge muscle guy but he's
like really fit ABS looks awesome and I
realized this is the point of business
like with the point of business and
money is like hey there's like some
practical reasons so providing for your
your family two it's fun and fulfilling
but three like the point is like to live
a really long and good life and the
really the best way to do that money is
maybe number two number one is just like
being fit and I wanted to spend 10
minutes talking about my personal well I
was like what do engineers say they say
like Tech stack marketing sack let's
talk about our body stack our pack stack
and I wanted to run run through all the
things that I'm currently doing and I
would put myself in the category of a
weekend warrior meaning I don't have
like formal education on this but I do
listen to podcasts and I read books and
I'm like self-educated which means you
know like I'm a b maybe or not not an
expert but uh I I try to read and learn
and teach myself
okay great go for it all right so let me
walk through so what I do uh and then I
want and I'll go first and then you
could go because I know you didn't
prepare so you can kind of like think
about it as I do it so what I do I do
four four days a week of strength
training and then the other three days
cardio those are usually lifting weights
or body weight uh stuff so that you're
working out every day you're doing seven
days or you take a rest day some days
you do two I do I do every single day
the day that I want to rest is uh I'll
just go for like a 15 000 step walk
which is like a two hour walk
um that's that's usually rust and then I
sleep from 11 to seven and right now I'm
around 11 or 12 body fat with and I have
a background in in athletics so I'm not
like a complete Noob but I basically
just learned all about this in the last
like six seven years I I used to just do
what I was told now I kind of know why
I'm doing what I'm told and my goals
with with healthy eating and working out
is basically uh three things one live a
long and healthy life two look good
naked and three uh like achieve certain
like fun goals like running a certain
race hitting a certain body fat
percentage lifting a certain amount of
weight just fun stuff but that's really
the simple stuff two people don't admit
that it's I just want to look good naked
you know what I mean that sounds weird
that's not weird you have to say that's
not weird might be a little weird
look I'm just saying what people think
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
so all right here's the products that I
use
for I spent 299 dollars a month 300 a
month and I have a trainer at Central
athlete uh it's a place in Austin I have
an app they just tell me exactly what to
do and if I have questions or an injury
or I'm traveling I text my trainer Jesse
and I say traveling let's adapt this
workout and then we meet once a month to
say all right here's the goals for the
next month let's try and do this here's
my goals for next year let's work
backwards uh the second thing I do is I
pay 600 a month for a daily call from a
nutritionist with my body tutor soon I'm
gonna switch to the 200 a month plan and
that's going to be a once a week call I
think but I spend 600 a month and
basically I have someone calling me
every day saying what's the plan today
for your diet
um let's work backwards from where you
want to go whatever it's a 15 minute
call the third thing is I spent around
three thousand to five thousand dollars
upfront cost and I built a home gym
maybe it could have been 2500 but I
think it was probably 3 500. uh the
second thing or the the another thing is
I do blood work so two to three times a
year I spend on average 200 to 300 and I
get I do inside tracker it's just a fun
way to track your blood uh and uh and
see like where you are and see if you
can improve things that were not so
great the the time before the next thing
is I get massage massages one to two
days a week at this place called run lab
in Austin which basically just I have a
history of calf injuries and so they
massage my calf and it's covered by
insurance so I pay I only pay about 20
bucks each time I go and then I do a
subscription to active have you heard of
active yeah it's like an audio workout
thing yeah I pay a hundred dollars a
year for that and so whenever I'm
traveling and I need to do a body body
weight workout like I did this weekend I
say I want to do a 60 Minute Body Weight
Workout and it's like a trainer in your
ears and I find that to be fun uh the
next thing is I do my fitness pal I
track everything I eat and I spend 60
bucks a year on that and then I spend
100 a year for fit fitive it's called
it's an whenever I do cardio I always
try to keep my heart right right at like
145 beats per minute if I'm doing like a
long cardio workout because that's like
perfect like I think it's zone three
zone two it's one of the zones that I
want to like stay in uh and then I
basically subscribe to Pandora I'm like
the only guy ever who pays money for
Pandora so I I paid money for Pandora
Spotify YouTube and Audible and I listen
to all those when I work out because I
love doing that next I have zero budget
for Whole Foods and healthy foods
whatever I see and I want I get I don't
question the price I just think I'm
doing it no matter what
and then finally I will probably spend
around a thousand dollars a year on
equipment so I have lifting shoes I have
like a lifting belt I replace my running
shoes consistently and I buy any type of
equipment that I need I always uh I buy
it and then finally I listen to Nick
bear you know who that is remember that
rip dude yeah he came on the Pod yeah
he's amazing So I listened to his
podcast and I listen to Mind Body Pump
that's another one of my favorite
Fitness podcasts and then I just follow
tons of rip dudes on Instagram and you
know they say you're the average of the
five people you hang out with most I
feel like I'm the average of like the 50
followers that I follow on Instagram so
I'm just constantly like seeing like
ripped dudes and like people running far
and running fast I get that on Instagram
so that's all my equipment I'm gonna
wrap it up with here's the rules that I
basically have for my fitness and my
health so I always have a goal with a
deadline meaning like next year my goal
is going to be to run a 100 mile race
this year was to hit body fat percentage
so I always have a goal number two I
always hire coaches if there's anything
I want to learn last year I learned
boxing I had a boxing coach this year I
wanted to get my nutrition right I had a
nutritionist I always hire a coach no
matter what
finally or the third one no processed
foods and no sugar unless it's planned
and and uh it's intentional so like I
know like two weeks three weeks in
advance this is a special occasion I'm
on a Splurge there I don't fret over
money if it makes me healthier and
finally I'm not trying to be perfect I'm
just trying to be the least bad most of
the time and intentional about when
uh I am gonna like Splurge so those
that's basically my whole thing a few
things in the future that I want
something what does that add up to the
dollar amounts that you just mentioned
did you sum it up by any chance uh well
so the I didn't have the exact cost in
my home gym because I spent about three
grand up front and then I've been like
buying stuff as I've gone yeah let's
call it five let's call it five grand
we'll call it five then I would say I
spend around fifteen thousand dollars a
year
and um you know like LeBron James has
this like this famous stat where it's
like a million dollars a year yeah he's
like I spent a million dollars a year on
my body and when that first came out
other athletes were like whoa uh you
know like other NBA guys were like I
don't spend anywhere near that but you
know you look at LeBron he's sort of
like the Pinnacle athlete in terms of
physical fitness even athletes and other
sports I've heard NFL's guys reference
that I've met NFL guys and they talk
about yeah LeBron said he spent this
that that got me thinking what am I
spending on why am I not investing in my
body Conor McGregor has said that he
goes I heard LeBron James says he spends
a million dollars a year I'm thinking I
didn't spend anything he's like and so
then he started like he hired it he
hired like full-time staff and people
and started doing the whole thing and so
I think that was funny how that one
person saying that
um
you know like triggered a kind of a
chain reaction and I actually think it's
smart that you're sharing this because
it's not our typical thing we talk about
on the Pod uh we'll joke around about it
but it's not like a usual segment on the
Pod but I think it is a big part of
being an entrepreneur and a Founder is
like
dude that founder 15 is real that
founder for me it was the founder 45
that was real dude I gained so much
weight stressing out eating wrong
sleeping shitty uh you know not work not
working out because I didn't have time
and that really costs you and so I think
it's great that you uh that you decided
to do the second and we didn't even talk
about it well oh yeah yeah the other
thing so we didn't even talk about
mental health stuff so the mental health
stuff like I try to like I just like I
write every morning and it's not like
dear Journal typically it's like here's
what I want to get done today like I'm
pretty bummed about this this and this
but I'm very thankful for this so like
that's my version of writing
um and then like obviously like lots of
therapy so those like my mental health
things but all right last thing the
things I want to try so one an Executive
Health checkup so basically you spend
some number between five and 20 grand a
year or 20 grand in one turn and you go
for three days to a Mayo Clinic and they
just do all type of stuff to you I'm not
convinced that it's entirely needed but
I I test everything just mostly for fun
number 2 a concierge doctor have you
ever had one of those briefly I had a
yeah I had a concierge doctor I had a
kind of amazing yes I had one when I was
one time I got really sick with lime and
my face like broke uh I had like Bell's
Palsy it was it was horrible so I spent
25 Grand I had a concierge doctor a
doctor on call and that was awesome I
want to get one of those the third thing
skin stuff do you do anything for your
skin like wear sunscreen no I don't do I
I dude I I haven't honestly I haven't
washed my face in like six years I might
be a white guy you know underneath all
this this might just be
sit down here like people are like I
want to face wash these I was like yeah
my face gets wet during the shower gets
wet that's that's the wash bro like
there's not there's not a routine
there's never left over on the towel
when I wipe my face off and dried off
it's the soap that I'm using dude I
don't know if it's a woman thing or if
it's a black woman thing because my wife
like knows everything about like skin
care she's like you got to use this then
you gotta do this you gotta do this and
I'm like dude that's just way too
complicated and I'm doing any of that
I'm just gonna use the hand soap but
basically uh I have to use sunscreen
she's telling me so I want to start
doing some some skin stuff and then the
last thing dude I want to do a five day
fast I was pretty inspired by John Lee
Dumas that's like on my bucket list it's
a five day faster those are some of the
things I want to try but that's my
that's my body stack
that's great have you heard by the way
have you heard how have you heard of
young people instead of saying um how
many people have you slept with they say
what's your body count
that's so funny it's so funny
he's catching bodies
that's right came up with this name
here's my body stack
some young woman raised her hand and she
goes hey teacher what's your body count
and I
think I've seen it in months
um all right so my buddy is uh going
through a company acquisition and he's
like oh yeah you know I'm gonna have to
earn it out there blah blah and I told
him I said you know when we got acquired
I did one thing really well I go I wrote
down I was like all right I know what
this year is all about
um it's this acquisition and I know this
could go many ways I talked to a bunch
of people who got Acquired and for some
of them they just got really depressed
they were bored at the acquiring company
for some people they had a great time
some people it was just sort of like ah
dude I don't even remember just sort of
like yeah you know whatever I don't know
that was years ago and I honestly I was
just kind of a zombie well I was on
autopilot I don't really I didn't really
have much intention behind how I spent
that year so I said all right I'm gonna
have some intent so I wrote this
document and I'm going to read part of
it to you uh you tell me when this gets
boring we'll switch it but I go my 2019
mindsets this is 2019 we got acquired by
by twitch where'd you write this you
said Google Docs and um at the top I
wrote
I wrote a quote time is what we want the
most but we use the worst I said this
document is a chance to think about how
I want to spend the next year of my life
time is the most precious resource
here's how I'm going to invest it I go
number one get fit enjoyably number two
earn and learn and number three become a
great person like Ramon those are my
three sections our buddy Ramon is uh is
the honoree so on the get fit enjoyably
I go every year I'm getting fatter Less
Mobile and I shorten my lifespan this is
a bad trajectory I need to invest now or
I'm gonna pay like I'm gonna pay later
hell I'm paying right now and I go I
think getting fit means dropping to 185
pounds feeling athletic and the word
enjoyably is really important every time
I've tried this in the past I start I
get motivated I take some action get
some results but it's hard I don't
really like it so I slip up and
eventually give up all together three
weeks what did you weigh then like 230
220 225 something like that I said three
weeks later I'm back on my couch and my
boxers eating chips and queso again this
cycle is bad long story short willpower
is not the not the fuel to use if I use
a willpower I fail instead I'm going to
find a way to do this uh in a way that's
enjoyable because when I like it I'll do
it
um so that means I got to figure out
foods that are clean that I actually
like I got to figure out exercise that's
good that I actually look forward to
doing here's what winning looks like I'm
185 pounds this is what I run at the
time I got nowhere close to this 105
pounds by the end of 2020 and with a new
set of exercise and eating habits that I
enjoy and I'm not forcing myself to
maintain all right so that was the the
first part a little a little letter to
myself I I'm proud of reading this I was
like you know I did not hit that goal
I'm not 185 even now I've probably
2 12 213 so it doesn't even sound like
much 10 pounds but it was but I probably
yeah it's a way to double that in terms
of yeah muscle mass composition versus
body fat dude in 185 for you A lot of
people don't realize this but you're six
one you think you're are you above
someone
yeah like you're that 185 would be
pretty small
yeah so I don't know I picked a number
but like specifics aside I think I got
the idea right and I don't want to look
back so at that time I was working out
zero times a week I was eating like dog
[__] and I was I really didn't have even
a game plan and in fact I actually had
very little
uh evidence that like this was doable
for some people if you've been in great
shape before you always have that you've
got that in your back pocket if I have
done this before imagine never having
done it right like never I never saw an
app it was the Loch Ness monster of my
body it was like where where is this
thing and so that was where I was at now
the two things that worked for me so in
terms of your text in terms of your body
stack I share two things uh but I do
everything else differently so
I also get a coach for everything that
I'm doing so I have a personal trainer
who I talk about a bunch I have a
nutrition I use the same once you told
me about my body tutor I do the 200 a
month plan where I text her every day
you dig it what I'm eating I dig it yeah
I've I'm not the most consistent with it
like I will forget to update it at night
I'll update it later but like whatever
just a little late
um
and um
uh yeah so I do the coach thing that was
really really important and like I was
saying with the MMA thing same thing oh
I want to do this let me get a coach and
a coach is not because you don't know
how to do it it's because it's like the
real way to commit to doing it and for
me I was like even better I need
somebody to show up at my house so I
looked at what are the things that trip
me up I was like it's not like I'm going
to the gym and doing a crappy workout
I'm just not going to the gym and so I
was like I need to find a way to go to
the gym I was like all right well what
if the gym came to me so I saw your home
gym I got inspired I was like dude
what's the flooring you used what's this
that you bought what's this I asked you
for every little piece and it was way
easier than you thought wasn't it oh
dude I copied the exact same thing I
bought the same rubber band it won a lot
of stuff it wasn't a lot of stuff and
you know a few kettlebells this that
great got it
um so got a home gym and then I got a
trainer to come to my house now
obviously this is a luxury not everybody
can afford to do this
but hey that's the point of this show
it's about like you know Building Wealth
and then figuring out how to use it and
so this is this is how to use it
um secondly was nutrition so okay the
coaching thing I'm right on board with
you mine was remove friction find the
places that like the Habit slips up and
just literally try to get rid of that
step so that was bringing the gym to me
the last piece was basically like what
is the what is the version of this I'm
gonna enjoy so I had to find a trainer
who I Vibe with who I actually like
hanging out with them
um like the conversation is fun it's not
just that they're good at their job and
secondly like we do workouts that are
fun for me sometimes we'll just he'll
come over and he'll be like let's go
play basketball we'll just go to 24 Hour
Fitness we'll play pick up basketball
it's kind of weird it's like dude you're
paying this trainer 100 to go play pick
up basketball with you it's like yeah
I'm actually paying for me to exercise
regularly and get in great shape I'm not
paying for a specific hour block of time
or a specific like skill set know-how
and so same thing MMA looks fun all
right I'm gonna do MMA
um we do training that's like about
Mobility sometimes or very simple things
like I'll tell them like look I told him
very simple he's like what are your
goals and I think for every other client
of his their goals are like I want to
lose weight I got a wedding coming up I
gotta you know I want to look good with
my shirt off blah blah blah you know
some [__] like that I was like when I
stand up from sitting I feel like an old
man I was like I don't get up like an
athletic person so that's my first goal
I want to be able to like we do this
exercise on the ground and you say all
right let's get up let's go over here I
don't wanna I don't want that to be like
a 18-point turn like I need to just like
get up not like oh yep come in hold on
this like straight I gotta get on my
elbow then my knee they might put both
hands on the ground too like you know
tripod then I'm up like that's that's
how I was moving honestly and I was like
same thing when I run I was like I don't
know if I run right I think my gate is
all messed up and so we spent a lot of
time literally fixing my walking gate or
my sitting posture or you know like my
habits for the morning of how to get
loose those things matter to me so I
would suggest also like don't make your
goals the cliche think about what
actually would feel good as maybe like a
middle step in between you and being
just like absolutely ripped because that
became very motivating to me and I
started to see results and all those
little things first oh I'm smoother when
I run I'm smoother when I walk I get up
more smoothly I can Crouch down in an
easier way and play with my kids that
was like I mean I could just sit in a
squat like those things were really
important and I had to find somebody who
knew how to who knew how to train in a
functional way like that not just all
right let's do you know three sets of 12
uh with a you know this heavy weight
that's it and do you set time aside for
like working out is it like everyday day
at this time
every day at the same time he shows up
at my house I'm not going to be rude and
leave him waiting I have to drop what
I'm doing and I go do it and that's it
and that's the whole thing so we do it
at three uh 3 P.M
um but it doesn't it could be any time I
actually prefer to move it to the
morning now but like whatever we do
three at the moment dude I don't like
Andrew Tate that much because I think he
says some silly stuff but he says a lot
of interesting stuff that I agree with
and one of the things that he said that
I've I've been obsessing over he goes
I'm not motivated I'm disciplined
and I thought that's beautiful that's a
that's a really that's a beautiful idea
and that has definitely that is
definitely key to achieving a lot of
goals whether it's work or uh Fitness
it's just like no I just like I don't I
I remember when I was starting my
business at like two o'clock people
would call I'm like hey let's go hang
out I'm like dude I gotta work and
they're like what are you talking about
you're the boss you can do anything you
want I'm like it's a and I remember I
was like 23 and I would say it's a
school night you know I can't go out of
school night uh you know like we had
these rules I was like bro I work I get
there at eight and I work until six
usually like I then I go to dinner like
I can't do these things and I remember
thinking uh I'm not motivated to do this
but I'm happy that I have this routine
because this is discipline whether I
kind of like forced myself to do it same
with Fitness same with anything it's
like motivation is a really good way to
get started but it's not a not the best
way to maintain discipline and you can
the cool thing about discipline is you
can kind of force yourself into it like
you like you set these things up like
this guy all you did was told this dude
to show up and now you're like [__] I
gotta do it I heard this great quote on
discipline because I always thought
about discipline like force being able
to force yourself to do something even
if you don't want to do it
and that's true that does happen but
that's not the definition and somebody
said this beautifully they go discipline
is just remembering what you really want
because like in the moment you want to
just sit down and rest or you just want
to chill you just want to eat that bag
of chips whatever but it's like okay
that is something I want but what do I
really want and if you remember what you
really want then you'll go do that thing
you'll go do the things that vote
towards that outcome versus this outcome
and so discipline is just remembering
what you really want it felt a lot
better than like that that's not that's
something I wanted to do versus
discipline being I forced myself to do
it even when I don't want to do it
appealing to me yeah it goes away like
the when you wake up in the morning and
you're sore yeah the the other things I
say are the things I do differently than
you is
um I don't set the specific timeline
deadlines so which is crazy to me
because like in business of course I do
that I will never set a goal without a
timeline I was like when I'm trying to
do it by if and if anyone on my team
tries to do that I don't let them do it
with Fitness I looked at it differently
I go look I've tried that before I've
tried to say I'm going to lose this by
this day my trainer kind of taught me he
was just like look
all right how old are you and I was like
uh at the time it was 32 or something
like that he's like all right 32 cool so
you've had 32 years to build up these
habits and now you're looking for a six
week you know a six week revamp like oh
you need this goal done in six weeks or
six months or
he's like the way I look at it you spent
32 years getting here maybe it's going
to take a little while to get there and
that's okay right like hey what's
another year you know what's what's a
year or two of working at this when you
spent 30 doing it the wrong way can we
spend a few doing it the right way
um and and he was sort of like what I
don't want is you work out and blah blah
then you uh you go and you doordash to
Taco Bell now you're feeling guilty and
you're eating the wrong thing because if
you're gonna eat it eat it and enjoy it
don't bring the guilt into it don't
bring the shame don't don't feel bad
that you're now it's a setback and have
this mental baggage about how bad it's
gonna be he's like just remember when
you're the dude who you like who you're
becoming you could eat Taco Bell it's
not even gonna mess with you he said I
could eat it I could eat Taco Bell every
day this week I won't change a thing
lift up his shirt still there right and
he's like that's who you're becoming and
so you just need to like focus on that
and don't don't like go through this
emotional up and down and up and down
and I'm so proud of myself for doing it
good one day and then I hate myself for
for missing it the next day and I feel
guilty like uh just like that's one way
you could do this but like how about we
just don't do it that way and so I've
gone very much the the tortoise not the
hair route with this which is just like
cool I'm gonna put no no timelines on
this I'm gonna put no I'm gonna make it
where it's unfailable my only goal is to
rebuild my habits of eating and exercise
to be healthy and I don't care how long
that takes I'm gonna do it and um and
there's no setbacks everything is
progress compared to how I was before
even how I was a month ago and so that
that has also helped me and is a very
strange thing because I've never ever
chased a goal doing it this way I've
never let myself just do it this like
infinite game style where it's like yep
there's no clock you're just trying to
be better today than you were yesterday
and like it's okay you know even if you
do something that's wrong you learn
something in that process too it's all
right uh you know this pat on the back
style I've never never tried it but this
is the first time
so in other news we're going to be
launching guy next door
fitness plan yeah dude we should totally
do that attainable attainable Fitness
[Laughter]
hot enough yeah we're gonna go Midwest
seven a New York six
yeah
that's amazing
[Music]
questions